MODERATOR: Welcome. Thank you all, and I know
you're all really interested in Ukraine because
you have waited out the weather over schedules
and cancellations and herewe finally are.
And of coursea lot ofthings have happened
even since we were originally scheduled to
do this.
Welcometo the Council on Foreign Relations.
You allI thinkknow the rules which are
to turn off your cell phones, and this session
will be on the record. I will make some introductory
remarks, talk to our panelists a bit, and
then open the floor for questions. And there
will be further instructions before the questions
start. And we will end promptly at 1:30.
Our subject today is "Inside Ukraine." And
obviously, that's a very timely topic. I think
we couldn't have two better panelists to talk
to us. Not only about what's happening inside
Ukraine, what should happen, what the future
may bring, and, equally important, what's
going on inside Russia. You have their bios
in the papers that you were handed. But let
me just give you some high points.
Ambassador John Herbst to my immediate right
is director of the Eurasia Center at the Atlantic
Council, with law experience and extensive
researchand writing in Central Asia, Ukraine,
and Russia, as well as distinguished diplomatic
service in the region, including as Ambassador
to Ukraine from 2003 to 2006.
Matthew Rojansky is Director of the Kennan
Institute at the Wilson Center, and he wasthe
founder of the Ukraine program at Carnegie.
He's an expert on U.S. relations with the
states of the former Soviet Union, especially
Russia and Ukraine. He too has extensive experience
in the region and has written a great deal
on it, which I'm sure you're all familiar
with.
Before we hear from them, I just thought I'd
give you a brief update on the latest events
regarding Ukraine. As you know, last month's
recommitment to the Minsk Agreement has only
been partially implemented. And I use the
word "partially" euphemistically. While there
has been more or less a ceasefire and some
movement of heavy weapons in some areas, fighting
has continued. The United States and its allies
and the United Nations have charged a continuing
flow of weapons across the Russian border
to the Russian-backed separatists.
After he met this morning in Geneva with Secretary
Kerry, Russian Foreign Minister Lavrov said
that weapons were being withdrawn from the
front lines. As his government has said many
times, he called on Ukraine to distance itself
from what he called "nationalist extremists
in its ranks," and to get to work on promised
political and economic reforms for the Eastern
part of the country.
Secretary of State Kerry has just finished
a news conference in which he said that the
Russians had cherrypicked the areas in which
there had been an actual ceasefire and weapons
had been withdrawn. He, as you know, last
week accused Russia of lying about its support
for the separatists. This weekend, he accused
Russia of what he called "craven behavior"
and"undermining the ceasefire."
He also said he spoke with Foreign Minister
Lavrov about further sanctions, and said that
he thought that there had to be something
substantive that everybody could agree on
happening—he said it two different ways.
First he said "in a matter of hours". And
then later he said "in a matter of days".
The leaders of Ukraine, Russia, Germany, and
France, who negotiated both of the Minsk Accords
have scheduled a telephone conference later
today to talk about its status and—to talk
as well about a new gas dispute between Russia
and Ukraine. Ukraine says that Russia's been
violating the agreement on gas they signed
last fall. And the Russian energy minister
is due to speak this afternoon with the EU
energy chief.
Meanwhile, as you all probably know, the United
Nations today issued a report in Geneva saying
that there were credible reports indicating
a continuing influx of heavy weapons from
Russia into the Donetsk and Luhansk regions.
The report estimated that more than 6,000
people have been killed since last April,
and that from mid-January to mid-February
alone this year, at least 842 people were
killed and 3,400 were injured.
As we all know, President Obama has said that
he's weighing a decision on whether to supply
the Ukrainian military with at least defensive
lethal weapons that have been requested by
Ukraine.
I wanted to start by asking Ambassador Herbst,
you were among the group of notables who recently
urged the President to make that decision
as a necessary means of restraining Putin
and Russia. Obama said he wanted to wait until
he saw the outcome of the newest iteration
of the Minsk Agreement. Do you think he's
waited long enough, and is it time to move?
HERBST: He's—he's waited far too long. The
ceasefire was violated overwhelmingly by the
Russian side, not simply the separatist side.
And, in fact, it's a fiction to talk about
them as if they're two separate entities.
The war in Ukraine is led by, financed by,
equipped by Russians, and there are substantial
Russian troops in Ukraine.
The ceasefire, according to the quote, unquote,
separatists does not apply to the one area
where all the fighting was going on, the Debaltseve
area. And of course, they conquered Debaltseve
before the fighting began to quiet down. Mr.
Putin is afraid of Russian casualties. The
Russian people have shown in numerous polls
conducted by the Levada Center in Moscow that
they don't want Russian troops fighting in
Ukraine. Mr. Putin is lying to his people
about his Russian troops being in Ukraine.
And casualties are a serious matter for Mr.
Putin.
Mr. Nemtsov was assassinated on Friday. Not
because he was a great opposition leader,
but because he was going to issue a report
characterizing the Russian troops who were
going to be—who were fighting in Ukraine.
So providing weapons to Ukraine will mean
more Russian casualties, which will increase
the cost on Mr. Putin as a political vulnerability.
And there's really no downside to providing
such weapons, because we're already accused
by the Russians not just of providing weapons
to Ukraine, but of having American special
forces fighting in Ukraine.
DEYOUNG: Is that the—is that really the
only reason why it's a good idea, because
it will increase Russian casualties? Because
I think there's pretty widespread agreement
that they're not going—you know, that Ukraine
can't win against Russia. So is that the primary
reason to do it?
HERBST: The point to this, the greatest challenge
to national security in the world today is
the revisionism of Mr. Putin and his(inaudible)
Moscow. They have ambitions that go well beyond
Ukraine. They claim the right to defend Russians
and Russian-speakers wherever they reside.
And Russian-speakers reside in great quantities
in two Baltic allies, Estonia and Latvia.
They also (inaudible) substantial number in
Kazakhstan.
Mr. Putin has conducted provocations against
the Baltic states, and his ambitions go beyond
Ukraine. You provide weapons to Ukraine, you
increase the price on Mr. Putin for his aggression.
That gives him less to fight with elsewhere,
wherever that elsewhere may be.
DEYOUNG: Do you—Matt, I've heard a couple
of speeches that you've given recently. And
you've said that—that arming Ukraine would
be courting disaster and would be pushing
Putin into a corner. Can you explain that
a bit why this is not a good idea?
ROJANSKY: Sure. Thank you for the question
and for this opportunity. I'm not—if I've
said that, I want to go back and check. Because
that's not quite the way I think about it.
I do nonetheless disagree with the recommendation,
respectfully. And even though I find some
of the analysis to be pretty persuasive. And
I definitely share Ambassador Herbst's conviction
that this is a major security challenge globally
and for the United States. I don't know if
I would put it as number one, but it's up
there. There's no doubt that it's up there.
I guess I have probably three clusters of
concerns right now. But the first thing that
I would say—and I think this is important
at this moment. You started us in a kind of
cross-section snapshot, where are we right
now. Where we are right now is that—this
is just a factual statement—this question
is functionally moot for the moment.
Andwhat I mean by that is the White House
made its disinclination to send weapons very
clear from what, two, three months ago? I
think we've heard that. That hasn't changed.
I think they've been very smart. I agree and
would support what the President and Secretary
Kerry have done in terms of this intentional
ambiguity, right? Using the fact that it's
been raised—you know, unlike Mr. Putin,
we don't control the public discourse in America.
And once the implicit threat has been raised,
use it, negotiate in the shadow of it. That
was very smart.
I think it's also moot because it's clear
that Paris and Berlin are not behind it right
now. And in that sense, that they also support
continuing to kind of wait and see as far
as Minsk is concerned. You know, look, the
problem with Minsk is that you can characterize
it more or less however you want, right?
If you want to characterize it as a complete
failure, you can do that. This is a confirmation
bias problem, right? If you go in looking
for an opportunity to say well, there's been
some shelling, there's been continued fighting,
so we have no ceasefire. That's an accurate
statement. We have no ceasefire, right? The
shooting hadn't stopped.
On the other hand, if you want to say we have
progress, right? People are alive today who
wouldn't have been alive if we hadn't had
a Minsk process. The line has stabilized in
place where it wouldn't have done so if we
didn't have a Minsk process.
And I would say very importantly, we have
a reaffirmation in a document, that you now
have major international players including,
importantly, Russia. That's not to say that
you that you take that promise to the bank.
But at least it's a statement that endorsed
a framework for the next stage, right,for
what does the timetable look like for how
you get to a new shape of Ukraine in which
the separatist entities and the government
in Ukraine could actually coexist. And then
the government in Ukraine can get about its
business, which is fixing Ukraine.
DEYOUNG: And why would that—why would that
process not be helped, rather than hindered,
by increasing the defensive capabilities of
the Ukrainian military?
ROJANSKY: Yes. I'm—I am all for increasing
the defensive capabilities of the Ukrainian
military. I want to be very clear about that.
And that kind of speaks to—to kind of the
first concern that I have out of—out of
three that I'm—that are sort of at least
worth raising here.
And this is one where I'm really open to being
persuaded. But I'm genuinely concerned that
the proposal to send weapons, this particular
proposal to send these particular weapons,
we don't know how it ends in terms of what
happens to the weapons. Are they used effectively
by the Ukrainian military? And I know that—I
know that senior Ukrainian security officials
told the group that went and visited—because
AmbassadorPiper hadmentioned this to me,
this is what they want. OK. I've been working
with Ukrainians for a long time. They tell
us a lot of stuff about what they want. (Inaudible),
you know that too. OK. It doesn't necessarily
translate to this is exactly what's going
to make the best difference that we can right
now pound for pound.
But the bigger concern is what happens to
the weapons in this conflict zone? So we saw—what
was it, about a week, week and a half ago,
that one of the three counter-battery radar
systems the United States has already sent—and
by the way, there was chatter about this two
weeks ago already. It was confirmed. It was
front page in the New York Times—is now
in separatist hands. Right?
So we have a kind of concern about an Afghanistan
scenario, where once you put the weapons into
the conflict zone, what happens? Do you just
end up with a lot more people dead? Do you
end up with a lot more civilians dead?
My second concern is the Russian reaction.
And I want to be very clear about this. I
don't mean I'm worried we provoke Mr. Putin
and he gets madder. Right? Mr. Putin's as
mad as he's going to be, right? He is a cold,
calculating, very difficult, nasty adversary.
I would say let's presume that he's going
to escalate. Let's presume that he's going
to behave absolutely as badly as he can.
Then the question you have to ask is OK, if
Russia is prepared to go to the nth degree
and to escalate against Ukraine and against
what it will then perceive as, in fact, you
know, explicitly a Western-backed Ukraine—though
I agree with Ambassador Herbst—that argument
is already made—and the Ukrainians lose
anyway. Do we want to have been called out?
Do we want to have been in the position where
we threaten hey, we're going to send weapons.
Of course, we're not going to send boots on
the ground. We're not actually going to intervene
to stop you. But we've been called out. Our
credibility's on the line, and the Russians
still win.
And then the last—the last concern I have—and
this is—this is sort of related, is to what
degree is the debate about this one particular
policy step a substitute for the conversation
we began to have earlier? Which is, what in
fact, does the West really need to do about
Ukraine? What is the strategic vision for
Ukraine? What's the conversation about Ukraine?
I'm concerned that there's a false choice
being set up here. If you support Ukraine,
you're going to send a bunch of crates full
of missiles. And if you don't do that, then
you're appeasing Putin the dictator.
Turns out, there are some other options. And
some of them are pretty decent options. And
I hope we can talk about those.
DEYOUNG: Well, I'd like to ask both just to
sort of go back and as scholars and people
who know a lot about this part of the world
over a long period of time to look back just
briefly on how we got here and—and whether
we truly understand what Russia is up to and—and
what—what role Ukraine plays in that.
Sometimes I think that with the sanctions
and everything, we—we sort of project what
we think would happen if similar actions were
taken against this country; that if the economy
tanked really badly in a way that was related
to an aspect of foreign policy, that people
here wouldn't stand for a government that
did that.
Are we—are we just projecting onto a system
in Russia that really doesn't work that way?
And at the same time, we're accusing Putin
of really being embarked on the first or second
or third step, depending on how you look at
the past ten years, say, of expanding Russian
influence in the region into the Balkans,
into—into the Baltic countries, and into
other eastern Europe places.
How much truth is there to either of those
things, in terms of what the reaction's likely
to be in Russia and what Putin thinks he's
doing? Whichever of you would like to talk
about that.
(UNKNOWN): Please.
HERBST: I will, if you don't mind, answer
your question. But also, answer something
that Matt said.
Yes, I'm associated with a group that argues
for the supply of weapons, defensive weapons,
to Ukraine. Not missiles, by the way. And
I think it's part—but that's only part of
the broader strategy that I would recommend.
And that's a strategy based upon the challenge
we're facing.
And again, I think the fact that the world—one
of the world's two largest nuclear powers
with one of the world's largest armies and
the sixth or seventh or eighth largest economy
in the world has dismantled borders in two
European countries within the last six years,
suggests we have a serious national security
problem. I say easily the most serious compared
to ISIL, which is getting all the attention,
compared to Iran, even compared to North Korea.
And if I think if we understand that, we need
to understand that the danger we're facing
requires a serious multifaceted response.
The weapons to Ukraine is just one aspect
of it.
The second point that you make, which is on
sanctions. Sanctions will seriously hinder,
seriously weaken the Russian economy, especially
given the drop in oil prices. A third element
that we need is a NATO policy which recognizes
the danger. What we did at Wales was highly
inadequate to the danger we face. There should
be a review of the U.S.-Russia relationship
in NATO.Excuse me,the Russia-NATO relationship,
the doctrine. There should be much more serious
deployment of Western forces to the Baltic
States, which are vulnerable if, in fact,
the Russians wanted to move. And again, we
should be providing arms to Ukraine.
And finally, the fourth element of our strategy
should be a wrapping up of radio free Europe,
radio liberty, all the information apparatus
of the West. Because Mr. Putin is running
the most comprehensive propaganda campaign
in world's history. And he is an admitted
admirer of Joseph Goebbels.
Now, you ask are we simply mirror-imaging
as we look at what we should be doing with
Mr. Putin. And the answer is no. We know this:
We know that Mr. Putin made a quote, unquote,
implicit deal with the Russian people, I give
you prosperity, you give me the right to do
whatever I want in power. And he's not delivering
on prosperity. And the sanctions make it harder
for him to deliver on prosperity. That's point
one.
Point two, again I already mentioned that
his—the Russian people do not want to be
sending soldiers to fightfellow Slavsin
Ukraine. So providing Ukrainians a way to
create more casualties is a serious impediment
to Mr. Putin's aggression.
And—and finally, if you understand that
Mr. Putin's ambitions go beyond Ukraine, even
the fact that he could escalate in Ukraine
and quote, unquote, win, he'll pay higher
price for that in terms of soldiers lost,
in terms of equipment lost. He'll pay a high
price forthat around terms of strengthening
the spine of Europe to maintain and strengthen
sanctions.
We need to understand that the problem we're
facing is not a Ukraine problem, it's a Putin
problem. And the way we beat him is in Ukraine.
Thank you.
DEYOUNG: You want to --
ROJANSKY: Sure, yes. So—so just on the last
one, I think about it a little bit differently.
I'm actually very glad to—to have the door
open to kind of the broader set of policy
responses, because I think it gives us an
opportunity to talk about OK, so why, in fact,
does Ukraine matter, right? Why should we
bother having a longterm interest in Ukraine?
You know, is Ukraine a part of Europe that
we want to be committed to? And why does Europe
matter to the United States?
The sort of questions that, you know, you
ask when you're having a serious policy conversation.
And when you're contemplating, by the way,
committing the kind of resources that I think
we would both agree actually will be needed.
And here we're talking about the sort of tens
of billions scale of resources.
You know, let's not forget how much money
the West put into the former Warsaw Pact countries
and the Baltic States coming out of 1989 to
1991 to get the result that we can all be
pretty satisfied with today, which is that
we have more or less, plus or minus, have,
you know, a pretty functional, big Europe.
The default glide path towards that has broken
down. We can't do the same thing again and
expect the same result.
In terms of the Russian side of that equation,
sanctions have absolutely worked, but depends
on how you define "worked", right? So sanctions
can do three things. One is they can send
a message. They have sent a message. They
have sent a very strong message. The Russian
economy is hurting. It is not exclusively
because of sanctions. It's not even exclusively
because of sanctions and the oil price. It's
because sanctions, the oil price, and ridiculous
structural dysfunction within the Russia economy
that any of us who've worked in Russia for
the lasttwenty-five years have known about
and seen, in fact, getting worse.
That message has been sent. I think a message
has been sent, by the way, to countries other
than Russia that might contemplate 'do we
want to change borders by force, do we want
to take this little piece of territory, do
we want to muck around in our neighbors?'
It's not to say that we'll stop them, right?
And this is the problem we have, too; we have
to think about, you know, this Putin problem,
as Ambassador Tefft defines it—excuse me.
Ambassador Herbst. That's a compliment, by
the way. I think very highly of --
(CROSSTALK)
HERBST: ... put that on John. He's got (inaudible).
ROJANSKY: I think very highly of both; that,
in fact, you know, there is the possibly when
your—when you'reinterlocutor or your adversary
simply isn't deterred.
And that's sort of point number two. Do we
change Putin's behavior through sanctions?
The answer so far has been no, right? It's
hard to foresee a sanctions scenario that
by itself transforms Russia's behavior in
Ukraine. For a whole host of reasons. But
I would just leave you with one, which is
that this has become existential for within
Russian domestic politics. In other words,
if Putin loses in Ukraine, it's pretty clear
that that's the beginning of the unraveling
of Putin's power and of the Putin system in
Russia.
It's much more than just the calculus 'I keep
you rich, fat, and happy and, you know, you
vote for me'. It's also the idea that he is
a czar, right? He is infallible. His vision
for what was going on in Ukraine was always
right, remains right, his predictions for
what happens next and his interventions areall
right. And if we prove that to have been wrong,
that will be the beginning of the end. But
the Ukrainians bear the biggest burden there.
And then I think the third piece of it is
what, in fact, happens in that comes to pass.
So sanctions, what happens in Ukraine,a lot
of other factors can affect whether the Putin
regime is long for this Earth.
If it's not, then we have to start asking
some questions that are going to completely
transform this strategic conversation in Washington.
What do we think about weak Russia? What do
we think about a disfunctional Russia? What
do we think about a Russia that's breaking
up into multiple Russias? An intensely nationalist
Russia? A caliphate in the north Caucusus?
An oil-rich, population-poor Siberian Russia?
These kinds of scenarios become actually quite
real and quite scary when we look at what's
happening to the Russian economy and the impact
that this Western punishment that we're talking
about, in fact, can have. You put all of those
together.
And then I would just say one last thing,
which is that if you look at—at what happened
this weekend, this really tragic murder of
Boris Nemstov. And let me also say, I mean,
I'm still in shock from that; right? I mean,
this—the man was the definition of, like,
life; right? He was very alive. Huge personality.
Whatever you thought about his politics or
his methods, to see him made into a lifeless
corpse stood up—you know, lying down but
pushed up right in front of the view of the
Kremlin, it's—it turns your stomach, and
it tells you that Russia has changed. Russia
is different today—Sunday morning than it
was on Saturday.
And so my message here is, Putin has, in fact,
opened a can of worms with Ukraine, with the
rise of this angry Russian nationalism which
is absolutely committed to a victory in Ukraine
at all costs that is probably going to be
a bigger problem for him and the stability
of Russia, to be totally frank, than it is
at the end of the day for the West. But that
also becomes our problem. That is huge, huge
problem.
DEYOUNG: Well, I think this gets to some of
the things that you were talking about, Ambassador.
Is it—is it—because of some of the possible
problems that—that were just outlined, is
it OK for the West to at this point allow
Russian—Russia to have a substantive influence
in Eastern Ukraine? I mean, for a true federalist
system in which that part of the country is
under Russia's sway. Is it—or has it gone
past that point? Do we need to put him more
in his place and not allow that to happen?
HERBST: OK. I think there's some implicit
understanding in your question, which are
in my judgment not quite on target.
What you have in Ukraine is a Russian, again,
led, financed, partly staffed, and certainly
equipped war against Ukraine. And the reason
why you have that is because the people of
the East did not rise up against Kiev. So
what you're really asking is, can the West
live with Mr. Putin essentially having control
because he established—he ran this hybrid
war in Ukraine's East?
The answer to that is yes, but there's one
person who can't accept that, and that's Mr.
Putin because that's not his objective. His
objective in Ukraine is this: his preferred
objective, he cannot achieve, which is to
have a government in Kiev which is compliant
to his wishes. And he cannot achieve it because
a substantial percentage, 80-90 percent, of
the Ukrainian people despise him intensely.
And I'm speaking diplomatically when I use
that formulation.
So his lesser objective, which is perfectly
acceptable to him, is to make sure Ukraine
is destabilized. What he cannot accept, given
his outlook, is a Ukraine, even a truncated
Ukraine, which is stable, democratic, prosperous,
and looking westward.
That's why—you know, this is now March.
You've had this crisis in Ukraine's east for
overeleven months. That's why, despite efforts
from every statesman west of Moscow to reach
out to Mr. Putin, we have never heard what
he needs to stop the fighting.Because what
he needs is not a specific territorial objective.
It's this objective of did he stabilize Ukraine.
And obviously, that's not something you can
say in polite circles.
So, I mean, I've said—I've been on record
of saying that if I was in Ukraine, I'd seek
to cauterize the East. Give Mr. Putin east.
In fact, I'd say you annex it. You paid for
it, you broke it. But of course, he doesn't
want that. He can't accept that. He needs
to continually move beyond the borders he
controls in Ukraine's east to destabilize
the country.
And people don't seem to understand this here.
And again, his objectives go beyond Ukraine.
They go throughout the entire post-Soviet
space and maybe else. He is the number one
menace to global security today. And until
it's understood in Berlin, in Washington,
London, Paris, we're not going to have the
right policies.
DEYOUNG: I have lots of questions. But did
you—did you want to respond, specifically?
ROJANSKY: No. I mean, look, I think—again,
I agree. We—we have a—we have a Putin
problem. We also have a Russia problem. And
we also have a Ukraine problem. The problem
is we have all of those problems.
And—and what that tends to suggest is—you
know, again, foreign policy's hard. That's
why we have these kinds of conversations.
We've got to figure out, you know, what are
your priorities? And then you've got totalk
about timing.
So my sense is there probably is a way or
less to bring the fighting to an end. And
I am reasonably—I'm not satisfied. That's
not the right word. But I'm relieved at the
degree to which Minsk actually has delivered
a reduction in violence. It is not complete.
We need to see more. But that gets me thinking
in terms of timing and sequence.
And I actually think there's a way. Because
the beauty of the situation—maybe the irony
of it—is I don't think—I don't think that
Putin has anotherten years ortwenty years.
I think Ukrainian project is aten year ortwenty
year project, just as the European project
was a half century project.
And I think if we can—if we can get an end
to the fighting in the immediate short term,
if we can transform this urgency—you know,
Ambassador Herbst mentioned polling numbers,
right? So yes, you're right. A huge number
of people hate Putin. A disturbing number
of people even now don't like Russians. Big
problem, right, when you have—your biggest
neighbor.
But more important than that, an overwhelming
majority of people are committed now to this
vision of European integration. There's even
a pretty large preponderance that wants to
be in NATO. That is a transformation of the
Ukrainian domestic landscape. That creates
an opportunity to actually fulfill a reform
vision in Ukraine that has never happened
intwenty-five years.
Because the thing about the EU and NATO, if
you take them seriously, is that they are
reform agendas. That's what they are, right?
Yes, there's Article 5. Yes, there's economic
benefit that comes with the EU. But in essence,
they are roadmaps to reform. They are how
to become a modern Western European, you know,
or Norther American-type country.
If Ukraine, in the sort of middle term of
this strategy, can transform that anger, the
urgency, everything that comes out of the
war and the feeling of frustration that they
have now into the kind of resolve they've
never had before. Never, ever. And I mean
on the elite level and the level of society
to fulfill the reform agenda, that will be
a victory, no matter what Putin continues
to do. No matter how much trouble he keeps
stirring up, that's the victory scenario in
the middle term.
In the longer term—and here I have to say
something that's difficult, but it's reality.
The longer term is you need to have a vision
for reconciliation and reintegration within
Ukraine and between Ukraine and Russia. And
if you don't have that, if you say "oh, well,
how can we talk about that because we're at
war"? Then you condemn yourself to a vision
of Ukraine that will be a failure, I promise
you that. Because Ukraine isn't Poland. It
is not 99 percent Polish and Catholic. And
it never will be.
DEYOUNG: Let's go to questions from the floor.
If you could, I'll point to you. And then
if you could wait for the microphone and identify
yourself and your affiliation. Yes, sir.
QUESTION: Thank you. Bill Courtney with Rand.
Very good presentation.
Mariupol is roughlytwenty times larger than
Debaltseve. The Russians had a harder time
taking Debaltseve and also the Donetsk airport
than they thought. The Ukrainian military
resistance at first was feckless. Now, they
appear to have learned something about fighting
in urban-like environments.
If Putin's goal is (inaudible) or even a land
bridge to Crimea, Mariupol has to bethe
next strategic target. Do you think Putin
would be willing to take the risk of taking
on a city that large?
ROJANSKY: Please. I'm --
HERBST: I don't think there's any question.
It's probably implicitly evident in what I've
already said; that Mr. Putin is going to strike
elsewhere in Ukraine because he can't let
things stabilize. He cannot have a true frozen
conflict, because his objective is to destabilize
the country. Mariupol seems to be the next
objective.
And by the way, I can in no way share Matt's
optimism about the ceasefire. Because we had—when
there have been quiet periods in the ceasefire—remember,
we hadin Donetskone ceasefire from early
September. The quiet periods have been used
by the Kremlin to send substantial assessments
of advanced equipment.
The most quiet period was between, like, December
9 and January 9. And that's when the Kremlin
sent in hundreds of missiles, tanks, armored
personnel carriers. Because their objective
is to go further into Ukraine to destabilize
the country.
Bill's right that the Ukrainian forces have
fought pretty well. Russia's lost a lot of
people. And the separatists have quote, unquote,
lost a lot of people at Donetsk Airport and
the Debaltseve. If they try to take Mariupol,
they'll lose even more.
But there will problems elsewhere. And Mariupol
seems to be the most likely, although not
the only place where they might strike.
DEYOUNG: Matt, did you want to --
ROJANSKY: Yes. I mean, my only—my only thought
on Mariupol specifically was that it was about
two weeks ago this conversation was in full
swing about, you know, is Mariupol the next
Debaltseve. And, you know, I had a conversation
with a Ukrainian friend where he just basically
pointed at the map. And he said, you know,
this land bridge thing is a fantasy. Maybe
it wasn't a year ago. Maybe Novorossiya a
year ago seemed like it could happen and it
would be this sort of boomerang-shaped thing
that would go all the way to Crimea and even
to Odessa and even to Transnistria, right?
This is a complete fantasy. It's not going
to happen.
The reason it's not going to happen though
is not because the Russian military couldn't
if they wanted to grind into dust everything
between the border and Odessa, right? I mean,
they have the hardware to do it. And if they're
ordered, they'll do it and it will be a horrible
catastrophe. But it won't end, right? It will
be an endless, insurgent-type war of the kind
that Ukraine has actually seen through a number
of different phases of its history. And it
would be a total nightmare.
Now, is it utterly—can I guarantee you right
now Mr. Putin will not do that? No, I can't.
It is within the realm of possibly. It seems
to me that if the conversations about Mariupol—and
this is the one thing that I find a little
irritating about the kind of Mariupol-is-next,
Mariupol-is-next mantra, is that that would
seem to me to be very unlikely. It doesn't
track with the path so far.
I do think—and if I could just comment on—on
this phrase that Ambassador Herbst used about,
you know Putin cannot let things stabilize.
Putin has to open a new front. He has to attack
somewhere. You know, that might be right.
The problem with that, if that's the reality
that we're dealing with, then there is only
one solution to this, and that's regime change
in Russia.
And that's an exceptionally fraught and dangerous
solution for the West. That's where I say
we have to have a much bigger conversation.
And I'm prepared to have that conversation.
But I'm not prepared to put the cart before
the horse and commit to policies that lead
to that without knowing where we're going.
DEYOUNG: Hand up here. Yes.
QUESTION: One thing that's different in the
--
DEYOUNG:Can youidentify yourself?
THE DEFENDANT: I'm sorry.Anton (inaudible)
from(inaudible).
One thing that's different in the toolkit
of American foreign policy ten years ago and
today is that the U.S. is not only becoming
energy independent, but it can export. And
it can export lots of gas, et cetera.
What signal would it give to Putin—just
fantasize here for a moment—if the United
States made it clear that it would be prepared
to do the (inaudible) the Berlin airlift and
say if you run short of gas, we'll provide
it no questions asked. Money, we'll discuss
later, but it will be there. Which it could
do.
HERBST: A very interesting question. I'm not—I'm
not an expert on hydrocarbons. But I'm not
certain the United States, even in its new
hydrocarbon wealth, has the ability to supply
all of Europe's needs with either liquified
natural gas or anything else.
Having said that, I concede your point. And
I agree, if we were to open up our energy
for export—which we'd have to do by law—that
would be a strong signal not just of support
for the Europeansvis-a-vis dealing with
the problem of Russian control over gas supplies
to Europe. It would also probably bring a
drop in natural gas prices over the world.
So I strongly support it.
DEYOUNG: Yes sir.
QUESTION: Bob Blake. Nobody's mentioned Germany
yet. And for our prime minister, where—it
seems to me that that's a key element there.
Where are things now, not only with—with
her and with her party, but with the German
business community? What—what kind of—of
limits does that make on our own policy?
DEYOUNG: I think—and and I would like to
expand that question just a little bit.
You mentioned NATO, Ambassador. It would seem
to me that NATO is pretty far from having
any kind of consensus about—about what to
do about expanding its activities in its eastern
members. And I think that the same disagreement
exists on—on some of these economic questions
as it does on—on the—on the—the military
questions.
So I wonder if either or both of you could
address that with Germany and the larger question
of Europe.
ROJANSKY: Sure. Yes. OK. So on Germany, I
can't speak as a Germanist at all. But I will
say that gosh, it's probably almost a year
ago at this point that I wrote a piece—I
think it was for CNN—in which one of the
main points I madeabout how you actually
deal with the security dimension and strategic
dimension of this crisis boils down mostly
to kind of 'let Europe lead'. Which might
sound very much like the sort of, you know,
leading from behind. You know, America should—not
at all, right?
The rationale on my side is I very much think
of the European project, of the post-world
WarII era and in particular, the post-Helsinki
era, to be the number one achievement for
American national security in—at least in
this part of the hemisphere. And for that
reason, I think kind of wagging that dog,
you know, from the American tail, was always
going to weaken a project that's already under
threat; for its own domestic reasons. You
know, within Europe, the (inaudible) and all
that business. But also for the challenge
that Mr. Putin has posed. So I am extremely
pleased—extremely pleased—with Merkel's
leadership role here.
Let me just say quickly three things. One,
short term, my understanding is that the German
business community will absolutely remain
a check, a break, but not a brick wall on
Germany moving forward with enhanced pressure
on Russia. That's probably not a bad thing.
Part of what I envisioned when I thought about
European leadership in this crisis was just
how much more—how much less political and
how much more sort of deliberate Germany has
to be when it thinks about whatit does vis-a-vis
Russia. That's a good thing. I like that style
of decision making.
Middle term, a German colleague of mine who
you all probably have heard from here in this
town, Constanze Muller, says the German—and
I think she's right. She says, "the German-Russian
strategic partnership is over." Right? So
I think of that as being a kind of middle-term
phenomenon. It's much than they've fallen
out of love but could fall back in love tomorrow.
But it's not saying Germany and Russia will
be foes for the next centuries.
But for the foreseeable sort of decades ahead,
Germany and Russia are not going to be holding
each other's hands in each other's respective
economic development the way that they have,
quite frankly, since even the Soviet era.
RememberAdenauer /Khrushchev; right? This
stuff has come to an end.
In the very longterm, I nonetheless believe
that Germany and Europe more broadly will
also have to play a leadership role in rethinking
what Europe looks like. What a new kind of
concert of Europe means, right? If you look
back at European history, you cannot escape
the conclusion that everyfifty to 100 years,
European powers have to get together in the
light of changing and shifting power and shifting
pressures and figure out what are the rules
of the game for Europe.
Russia has to be at that table, whoever is
at the helm of Russia. Germany has to be at
that table. I hope we're at that table. But
it's not going to be our table. It's going
to be Europe's table.
HERBST: I would agree with everything Matt
said. But I would add a few items.
Of—on Germany. When Chancellor Merkel was
here a couple weeks ago and saw the President
and it was clear from what they said publicly
that while Germany would not agree and they
would not support, would not send weapons
to Ukraine, they would accept an American
decision to do so and it would not lead to
any serious problems between Germany and the
United States. And they would work to—the
Chancellor would work to maintain unity.
I've been going to Berlin since this crisis
began. And I can tell you this—reaffirm
Matt's point that the—there's been a change
in the calculations in the Chancellor's office,
as well as the public. There's a much bigger
appreciation of the problem that Mr. Putin
represents. Although I don't think they understand
it completely, but they've come a long way.
The last point, and one area I do disagree
with Matt, which is that the proper response
for dealing with this crisis absolutely requires
American leadership. Because every time in
the post-Cold War—excuse me—in the post-war
world, even going back to 1945, when you've
faced a serious security challenge in Europe,
it was American leadership that was required.
Chancellor Merkel has been in the lead because
President—our president has given her that
role. Now, if he does not understand that
we face, you know, an extraordinarily great
crisis from Mr. Putin, then he doesn't have
to get involved. And therefore, he's let her
lead. But given the fact it has to be a strong
security response to the Kremlin; response
within NATO as I described, response as part
of a group for arming Ukraine, the United
States has to be out in the lead. And without
that, you will not have the proper policies.
DEYOUNG: But do you think the President doesn't
understand?
HERBST: I would say the policy demonstrates
that the understanding is not as strong as
it should be.
DEYOUNG: Diplomat. Yes, sir.
QUESTION: LloydHand, Kingand Spalding.
In trying to be brief, sometimes it leads
to oversimplistic questions. I understand—--
first of all, I should say thank you for a
very informative analysis assessment, prescriptions.
It seems to me it boils down to this central
question of the risk management of providing
lethal defensive weapons and what the consequences
may be. Or when you look at alternative sanctions—I
mean the leverage, it's sanctions.
With the divisions you just described within
Europe, I'm reminded of a conversation I had
with an ambassador of one of the countries
who's intimately involved in those discussions.
And what he said is, neither Europe nor the
U.S. is willing to go to war over Ukraine.
If that's a fact, it seems to me that the
leverage, from what you have said, that involves
less divisiveness among the parties, is increased
sanctions. Now, I heard what you said about
maybe the sanctions are a third of the economic
plight. But if—if what I read about the
continued—or lowered—decline in oil prices
is correct, about anothereighteen months
to two years, nobody probably knows beyond
that, then it seems to me that there's less
risk in managing these unlikely choices, to
increase the leverage in which it seems that
all the parties are in agreement.
Just taking advantage of thesub-minor question.
Going back to initially we were talking about
Kerry saying that Lavrov was lying. Don't
we have, with advanced technical means and
advanced technology, the capability of determining
unquestionably the extent of Russian troops
and equipment in Ukraine and the ability to
make that known so that there's no equivocation
about that? Thank you.
ROJANSKY: Excellent question.
DEYOUNG: Would you like to address that.
ROJANSKY: Excellent questions. Yeah. Well,
but thank you. You've got it. This is great.
So number one, we have—OK. I'm not privy
to classified information, nor am I revealing
any here. We have a lot more than the United
States government is publicly revealing about
what is actually going on on the border, on
the ground on both sides; who has been responsible
for some of the different massive civilian
tragedies and infrastructure destructions
that we have seen.
Why we have been so parsimonious about it,
even to the point of releasing kind of ridiculously
grainy satellite images that people in the
blogosphere are making fun of because it's
so obvious that it's not at all what our capabilities
can do, I don't know. I don't understand.
Because it seems to me that when you're in
what is clearly an information war, a war
in which sometimes what matters more is the
spin that's put on things than what actually
happened; more clarity, more transparencies
is very much to our advantage.
If we have a policy that's grounded in reality.
If our policy's grounded in an imaginary scenario
that isn't actually provable and based in
fact, well, then, you want to conceal something.
But that's exactly the wrong message to send
to the Ukrainian people and the Russian people.
Because they're already predisposed in this
kind of post-Soviet cynicism and konspiratzia,
the sort of conspiracy rumormongering, et
cetera, to assume that we are, you know, doing
more than we say we're doing and more so on
and so forth. So I would absolutely argue
for enhanced transparency and enhanced information.
You know, eyes on the ground. Very simple.
One positive note on that—and again, Ambassador
Herbst can accuse me of being the—the eternal
optimist here. The OSCE special monitoring
mission now is about doubling down on its
staff. That's really, really good. And specifically,
I saw the announcementbecause a friendwho
happens to be in the personnel department
there sent it to me. They are specifically
looking for people, at least from the U.S.
complement, with national/technical expertise,
who know how to deal with satellite intel
issues. That's an extremely positive step.
It's something I've been calling for for nine
months or so.
And just very quickly on your question about
the spectrum of the threat, this has been
one of my concerns all along. Which is, you
know, let's assume, as my colleagueAndrey
Illarionovlikes to say, Putin is, you know,
a mugger, a bully in a dark ally, right? If
you're going to up against someone like that
and your response is going to be a threat
back down or else, it shouldn't be a threat
that says 'back down or else defined as between
this and this, but nothing more than that'.
And that sort of is my concern with the whole
discussion. We will only ever get approval
to send weapons—I want to be very clear
about this. We'll only ever get approval to
send weapons if there is an ironclad guarantee
about what the ceiling is on that; that it
doesn't lead to a mission creep that ends
up with American boots on the ground. We know
that. So why threaten something that you know
is inherently limited when you're going against
an adversary who sees this as a survival issue?
It seems to me it just won't work.
HERBST: Great question, great answer. But
let me offer some additional, not necessarily
completely consistent, observations.
First of all, I agree with you that sanctions
are a good tool. But that doesn't mean that
providing weapons is not a good tool. And,
in fact, we have created mischief for people
who needed mischief created around the world,
for example, during the Reagan years with
the Reagan doctrine. We provided arms to folks
fighting Communist allies, whether it was
in Angola, Afghanistan, and elsewhere, Namibia,
Tanzania, to some real effect.
And the fact that Mr. Putin is willing to
spend more of histreasury on it doesn't
mean that these methods are not going to take
a toll. Which is what we want to do. We want
the aggressor to pay a price. That's point
one.
Point two on intel, Matt's absolutely right.
We should be providing more information. Just
like the White House should not be talking
about the Russian incursion into Ukraine;
it should be taking about the Russian invasion
of Ukraine. I don't know why we're not doing
it. I do know this, however: If we accurately
describe what the Kremlin is up to, the pressure
on the President to take more effective action
will grow. And he clearly does not want that
to grow. That's point two.
Point three, Matt's part—Matt's observation,
with which I agree, that it's foolish to say
you're giving weapons if at the same time
you're saying you're giving X amount of weapons
and you'll never give more. That would be
a mistake.And I tend to agree with Matt
when he says that's the only way we're going
to do it. And the only reason why that's true
is because there's a failure of leadership
in Washington. If Washington understood the
gravity of this crisis, it would maintain
that ambiguity, even as it sends weapons into
Ukraine.
My argument is that we need to have more serious
leadership on this issue in Washington. And
that's lacking. That's unfortunate. Because
again, this is the signature foreign policy
crisis of this administration. And while they've
done well on sanctions, they've done very
poorly on the larger security geopolitical
aspect of this; whether in terms of helping
Ukraine fight aggression or gettingNATO
prepared for possible Russian games beyond
Ukraine.
DEYOUNG: Yes.
QUESTION:Anya Schmemann,American University.
So most conversations about Ukraine turn into
conversations about Russia, which is understandable.
But let's focus for just a minute on our sick
patient in front of, Ukraine.
Even if there is a successful ceasefire, Ukraine
has significant challenges. What does Ukraine
need to do to solve its economic problems,
its political problems, its military problems?
And how do you assess Poroshenko's own future?
ROJANSKY: Sure. Thank you, Anya. So I have
been working on this Ukraine cluster of problems
for a while. I was what, sadly, I think, will
be the last Title 8, that is U.S. Federal
government-funded fellow to work for Ambassador
Tefft in Kiev before he left and then went
to Moscow.
And I worked on this problem called "corporate
raiding." And you can kind of imagine from
the name what that is. It's sort of like a
hostile takeover, but with a lot of guys with
guns and with an extremely murky can sense
of, you know, kind of corporate rules grafted
on top of it.
That problem, believe it or not, is worse
in Ukraine now than it was under Yanukovych.
And it was extremely bad. It was a tens of
billions of dollar scale problem under Yanukovych.
It's worse now in part because everybody's
fighting over the spoils of what Yanukovych
and the family left behind. But more so because
the irony is, at least under Yanukovych you
had a kind of monopoly on force. Now you have
private armies. Which means either the oligarchs
are literally sending their private—their
boys with guns to take stuff that belongs
to someone else that they want, or, they're
just for hire. You just have a lot of people
with a lot of guns, and you have a general
atmosphere that lacks any real sense of rule
of law. This is on a high level, but this
is also on a low level.
So, you know, what do you do about that? Well,
it's a huge problem; right? This isn't something
you flip a switch, you know, in an IMF program,
click, you know, nine months later we're done,
right? This is a deep-seated kind of—here's
one way I put it. When, you know, Sasha, the
Ukrainian businessman cannot wait to drive
home to complain to his wife about the corrupt
official who's trying to, you know, extort
a bribe from him at work and he gets stopped
by a traffic cop because he's speeding a little
bit; when his instinct stops being 'slip the
guy 500hryvnia so he can get home faster
and keep complaining', and becomes 'I'll see
you in court, I'll follow the rules, I'll
pay the fine', et cetera, et cetera—in other
words, a bottom-up change—then we have different
Ukraine. We're very, very far from that.
In the short term, some simple things you
could do; right? The Rada has already passed
a reform package. But at the last minute—and
this doesn't surprise me at all, given who's
in this Rada and the fact that, you know,
a huge proportion—I won't specify how many
because I don't know—are very much under
the sway of the most powerful and now well-armed
oligarchs in the country.
They stripped out the criminal penalties for
the most critical pieces of thisreform package,
including the law on beneficial ownership.
It's a very important law, because it says
who owns what. Otherwise, everything's held
by a hundred different layers of shell corporations,
and you don't even know who owns something
to begin with, right?
This is not beside the point, guys. Violence
in Ukraine, chaos, corruption, it all happens
over who gets to own and control the sources
of national wealth. I mean, Ambassador Herbst
knows this story very well from his time as
ambassador. So that's the first thing you
fix.
The other thing you fix is, you have a vision
for getting the guns out of the hands of the
people who shouldn't have them, and for getting
some kind of national project, some kind of
something in the way of national reconciliation,
so that people who live in one part of the
country don't feel like they have to raise
private militias and rely on these local kingpins—warlords.
Warlords are the right term. We should call
them warlords—in order to defend them against
people in another part of the country.
And I'm not only talking about Donbass versus
the rest of Ukraine here. I wish it was that
clean a division. It's nothing even remotely
like that. So the scale of this problem isactually
so enormous, Anya, that this isn't the kind
of thing that, you know, the IMF experts are
going to just write up a list andYatsenyukand
his emergency cabinet meeting last night can,
you know, adopt all of these things as new
law, sign the papers, and they get $17 billion
and it's done. It's nothing even remotely
like that. I'm sorry.
DEYOUNG: Did you --
HERBST: I'll answer much more quickly. The
differences in Ukrainian population between
east and west is much less than many commentators
have expected and assumed. And while there's
a need for a certain amount of autonomy in
the east, especially in the Donbass if Ukraine
ever reestablishes control over the Donbass,
that is a manageable problem.
The problem of overall reform of Ukraine is
an enormous issue. And it's as important as
defending Ukraine against the Kremlin's aggression.
On reform, you certainly have the best government
and the best Rada in Ukraine's history to
address this. You certainly have at the lower
policy level and among many Rada members legitimate
reformers. And that's wonderful, for the first
time in Ukraine's history.
It's also true that Poroshenko andYatsenyuk
represent the best leadership that the country's
ever had to address reform. But it's also
true that they may not be good enough. I know
them well. I think they both understand that
reform is important. I think they're also
both used to dealing in the back rooms and
in the corrupt ways that have been critical
to success in the country in the past.
I give Poroshenko reasonably high marks as
a national security leader dealing with this
Kremlin aggression. I would give him at best
a C-minus as a reform leader. I wouldn't give
him an F. Because, in fact, the --
(CROSSTALK)
HERBST: Well, no. Because the legislation
put before the Rada was not bad. It represents
an improvement, even with the problems that
you referred to. The point is, however, it's
not good enough, in my judgment.
I think that the West has a policy of tough
love on this subject, which is not followed
sufficiently closely. I think that the—it
was not a coincidence, as the Soviets used
to say, that Christine Lagarde offered the
IMF package as Poroshenko was wavering on
signing Minsk Two, which was a disgrace as
a document if you look at the things put on
Ukraine.
So I think for reasons of sympathy on the
security side, the IMF and the West has not
been as tough on the reform side as it should
be. And that's a problem. So to my mind, coming
back to Matt's need to have a policy which
encompasses everything, the West should be
much tougher on the security issues in the
ways I've described. But also tougher on the
reform side. This will be the fastest path
both to contain a revisionist Mr. Putin and
putting Ukraine on the path which will have
it developing—I agree with Matt, not as
nicely and as neatly as Poland, but along
that track.
DEYOUNG: We only have a few more minutes.
And so why don't we take two or three questions
and just give your questions in a row. And
then I'll turn the floor over to our two speakers.
Yes, sir.
QUESTION:Hans Binnendijk from SAIS andRand.
So I'd like to follow up on the question about
Germany and Mariupol.
A number of conservative German politicians
close to Chancellor Merkel have been talking
about what you might call the Mariupol test.
That is, if the Russians break out of the
current area in which they're in and we see
an effort to take Mariupol, that would be
the trigger for both their support for the
provision of defensive lethal weapons, but
also for an increase in economic sanctions.
And that kind of an approach would tend to
bring together the allies, rather than divide
them, and would also have the—would contain,
rather than try to roll back, which is very
hard to do as much as I'd like to. So just
give me your thoughts on why that wouldn't
work.
DEYOUNG: And do we have one more? Yes.
QUESTION: Jason Rockett, Greenmantle. The
one side of Russia that we haven't really
spoken about is the eastern side. And historically,
the U.S. has used its relationship with China
and Japan to put pressure on Russia in cases
where Russia was applying pressure on Europe.
We haven't really seen any of that in the
last year. And I was wondering what kind of
practical and realistic optionss do we have
there with our allies?
DEYOUNG: OK. Who would like go first on that?
ROJANSKY: Sure. OK. Just on—yes. On Mariupol
test. If I understood your actual question
at the end correctly, you're saying why wouldn't,
then, additional sanctions and weapons work
at that point?
QUESTION: Do you support the idea?
ROJANSKY: Do I support the idea. So my answer
to that is basically—so I think your analysis
of the Mariupol test is probably right. I
think that's an accurate diagnosis of European
and American politics at this moment. Which
is part of why I said for now, it's kind of
moot in watching them. But that's only for
now. If we get to that, if think you're right,
we'll have transatlantic unity.
I think you can put the line wherever you
want to put it. You can put it at Mariupol.
If you want to put it another hundred kilometers
in, you know, pick another target, Sloviansk,
you can do that too. My question is still
going to be—and to get me onboard, whatever
the policy is, is going to be OK, what then?
What is the vision?
So if the vision is, so then we're going to
send X amount of weapons, then I actually
agree with Ambassador Herbst; A, you need
to preserve genuine ambiguity within the threat
so that it's a real threat. But you have to
know why it is that you're prepared to escalate
to that level; to X amount of weapons, to
X-plus-ten amount. And then to whatever it
might take to get ultimately where you probably
need to go—and this is where I sort of hedgingly
and cautiously probably also agree with Ambassador
Herbst—that Putin probably isn't going to
stop. He probably will look to open another
front.
And if that's the case, you really have to
be committed. And if you're committed, you
have to know why you're committed and think
about where it ends. If it does end with us
being in a proxy war or a real war with the
Russians. If it does end with scenarios where
we are looking to undercut the Putin regime
so much, including, you know, backing internal
opposition to the hilt, taking him out, whatever
those strategies might look like, this is—you
see, I'm saying—so this is scary stuff,
right?
But we're through the looking glass here.
Once we declare—what I don't want to do
is I don't want to declare an American line
and then answer that with either nothing or
with something that is very clearly inadequate
that he—you know, he says I see your rockets—not
missiles. Sorry—I see your rockets and I
raise you more rockets.
That's the scenario I don't want to be in,
right? So if we follow through, we have to
know why we're following through and where
it ends. And I would hope, in fact, Europe
is in the lead in that conversation. Not because
I'm afraid of American leadership. I agree
on every rhetorical and political level. And
if I were writing speeches for the President,
I'd write them very differently. But because
I think Europe has a much better sense of
where it ends, and why it matters where it
ends. You know, our neighbors are Canada,
Mexico, and fish. Their neighbors are Russia.
They know how this stuff works.
And then just on China—not a China expert.
The one thing that I have observed—you know,
obviously, we've got—we have Japan and South
Korea to the extent that we were going to
have them. It's always going to be less than
we want and slower than we want. But the problem
that I see with China—I talk to a lot of
Chinese journalists much more so lately because
they're always very eager to know what are
we going to do in terms of sanctions.
My sense is not only, you know, is there this
sort ofschadenfreude that the Chinese are
thrilled to see this Russia-West, you know,
partnership come apart at the seams. But there's
also a sense that the Chinese are the first
major global economy to begin hedging against
the Western-dominated global financial and
trading system, that they look at the sanctions
and they read it a little differently than
we do. We say Russia has broken the rules
and so Russia is outside the system and so
Russia has to be punished.
They look at it and they say no, no, no, the
rule was this was going to be an apolitical
system that was going to be a level playing
field for all of us. You, the West, have violated
that rule by making it political. So we are
going to, on the margins at least, shift resources
out of the system and try to come up with
an alternative. That's—it's just one more
thing we have to take into account.
HERBST: OK. I'll start with China. I'm not
sure that there's much of a card for us to
play with China. Because China's actually
one of the beneficiaries of this current crisis.
Whether it's because Russia may be willing
to sell them gas at a reduced price or it's
because as Russia tears up the international
system, China sees precedence it can use in
the seas nearby. So I don't think they'd be
a balancer for us againstMr. Putin.
Regarding Hans' point, I think the Mariupol
test would be wonderful. I think that would
finally have Europe setting down clear lines
and letting Mr. Putin know in advance that
he pays a higher price for aggression. And
I agree as well with Matt's point that it
need not be Mariupol, it can be somewhere
else.
Because again, for reasons I provided for
analysis—per analysis I provided, Mr. Putin's
not going to stop. So he will run up against
that line. And that will begin to establish,
in Europe as well as hopefully in Washington,
the strong policies we need to deal with him.
Hopefully in the Ukraine. But if not in Ukraine,
then beyond Ukraine.
And I don't share Matt's view that it'll be
a national catastrophe and loss of American
prestige if we provide weapons and Mr. Putin
nonetheless conquers parts of Ukraine. We've
done that in the past and we've let people
know in the past yes, we are willing to provide
weapons for conflict X, but not put American
soldiers on the ground.
But as part of a long game to keep Mr. Putin
in check, it's a smart move. And the downside
is relatively small. In fact, the downside
really doesn't exist. Only in the minds of
people who are overly cautious and don't want
to see the real danger.
ROJANSKY: Wait. No—no, I have to disagree
with that. Because --
DEYOUNG: Briefly, because we're really out
out of time.
ROJANSKY: Because I think the downside is
for Ukraine, right? So—so Anya had the right
question about what happens to Ukraine. And
the downside, if all we get is a massive upsurge
in fighting and Putin wins anyway and Ukraine
remains dysfunctional anyway is we end up
with 50,000 more dead Ukrainians. That's a
pretty big downside.
HERBST: But the Ukrainians want it. They're
asking for it.
ROJANSKY: Well, again, that's to my point.
With all due respect to my Ukrainian friends,
you know, that may not mean that we should
give it to them.
HERBST:...father knows best.
DEYOUNG: I think we're all going to have occasion
to be back here and continue this conversation.
So thank you all very much. And particularly,
thank you so much to our speakers.
END